well you talked about the film being
about problem solving I think how did
you learn how to be a better
problem-solver because I think we get
such a narrow focus whoever it is in our
life and especially if it's our film and
we're seeing it on a timeline how did it
teach you to be a better problem solving
well you know our film if you build it
is about it's really about what we call
design thinking which is these two
teachers came into a small town a small
high school in North Carolina and they
were asked to teach the students how to
become more creative problem solvers or
how to how to learn what design thinking
is and how to apply it to your own life
and design thinking is is really just
sort of a process by which designers and
engineers and architects look at a
problem and there's sort of a structure
that is involved in in in how to become
a better design thinker there's
researching a problem there's what we
call I da ting which is throwing a bunch
of ideas against the wall on yellow note
pads or three by three by five cards or
writing it on a whiteboard call that I
da ting Emily calls it that you develop
an idea which is sort of you take two or
three the best ideas and pull them
together then you build a prototype for
what that solution might look like maybe
it's a model maybe it's a drawing maybe
it's something like that you refine that
prototype that's the fifth step refine
and then you build it then you take that
idea of yours and you build it and
that's really rubbed off on us so
whether we're working on a film or
whether we're doing something around the
house or whatever it is like I think
sometimes people people have this
problem that some militaries
struggle with which is ready fire aim
and I think design thinking really
encourages you to say ready aim really
aim and then fire that it's it's there
are so many solutions in our world that
have created more problems than then
there were before before before the
solution was introduced and I what we
what we tried to show in this film is
that anybody can become a better
creative more creative problem solver
and and that's what I love about the
film so much I mean it's it so it's a
really sort of an inspiring story about
becoming better at what you do whatever
you do
you